I'm coming for you that's how we record
audio wait we have my half asian a
lawyer the Kraken busy busy busy day of
course do tweet this out hashtag Vox ad
pocalypse right now it is trending
number four incredible cheese that's
that's this figs is also trigger it is
actually the Keebler elves are going
nuts gentlemen my legacy on the bisque
Oh must be happier grape filling just
know just Newton all that that's an
opportunity missed all right
and so we're gonna get to some exclusive
info and actually some live legal
updates here because we are waiting on
some information from you too but we do
have some exclusive info that you won't
find anywhere else so okay everyone I'm
trying to think of where to start here I
know it's like drinking from a firehose
in case you don't know I've been making
a lot of executive decisions today a
little bit tired but just a little you
know there was a past there was a New
York Times article that went up this
morning okay and they were talking about
the new YouTube policy which which
Carlos maza has been complaining about
by the way spoiler alert
not a big win for you Carlos is still
furious very I love it and the rumors
are true
YouTube did completely they completely
didn't just do monetize our videos
booted us from the partner program
altogether of which I was one of the
original members actually my yeah back
to 2009 and they didn't really give us
reasoning necessarily yeah but there was
this article New York Times YouTube
policy they were talking about their
policy this is important to note because
these stories all mesh together
destroyed Lynette New York Times where
said YouTube has a new policy and
they've since reviewed and removed
thousands of videos that are you know
white supremacist videos that are videos
of hardline bigotry and harassment
keep in mind for context out of those
thousands of videos at least a few
hundred hour hours yeah they didn't make
a delineation between white supremacists
and jokes we ready to make a difference
between Nazis and this
program that's important to keep in mind
because a lot of people read and go well
it's great to purge white supremacist
videos well that's why FIGS is trending
because this is considered amongst them
now what are my greatest sins I don't
know exactly I would say that you know
it's it's not it hasn't quite been like
this I think we have a clip of yeah
hasn't been as bad as this you're the
president but you're turning into a real
prick tater in fact the only thing your
mouth is good for is being Vladimir
Putin's holster sometime at night Pablo
look up in sky and say what the hell
going on up there the Indian soldiers
would run out on the battlefield and
that'd be like time for da do something
about your dad's immigration practices
you feckless [ __ ] and by the way I think
those should be acceptable when we
choose to bleep our own channel by the
who doesn't bleeping cease it forces us
to it's just because we've tried to play
by these rules for a very long time
frame and again included in these videos
all of the videos demonetised on our
channel all the videos have been booted
would be things like reading the green
New Deal I'm pro-life changed my mind
the students debate which was actually
having just students have a concurrence
with each other I had almost nothing to
do with it they were talking themselves
these have been D monetize that's right
alongside white supremacist videos and
want to bring this up yeah first off let
me let me tell you this this really
isn't that big of a ding for us that's
why we have mug club by the way we do
have a promo code right now everyone
everyone will get the $69 student price
for the next two days the aventurine
promo code it's free speech at La Toya's
Crider comm slash mug club that's
entering the promo code free speech we
do need it more than ever because we get
no revenue from games not at all but all
that's really changed for us just so you
know is that most videos were
demonetized we got very little revenue
from ninety percent and now we get no
revenue and here's the thing us everyone
here this is 15 people who work a lot of
credit summer tell them for yeah and I
don't know exactly um they are dependent
on Mudd Club we would all gladly give up
all monetization if it just meant that
we got to keep the reach that we've
acquired ourselves meaning you hooves
you who decided to get notifications if
we get to keep that we're ok because
we'll make it with people joining up at
my club right people buying merch but
particularly my Club will take that we
have sponsors like Walter we're not
really beholden to the YouTube
advertisement and that is why Carlos
masa is so upset this is what people
need to understand okay this isn't
Carlos masa this is absolutely Vox a
billion dollar company that is going
after a voice that is more effective
than them at dealing with their
misinformation and now that extends to
late night comedy that's what it extends
to at this point okay
they aren't happy because they've
expressly outlined that they want
everyone who disagrees with them to be
removed
you were saying hey what I don't crowder
those guys have been demonetised all I
ever wanted was for them to be destitute
because I claims there's a bully hood I
want to make sure that no one there
including low-level employees have no
ability to make a living there but you
know what that's not what they want they
want to make sure that no one is allowed
to express an opinion at all and this
guy Carlos mother talked about how
YouTube was a queer space hold on a
second let's put this in context again a
lot of creditor comes luck the
free-speech hashtag is what when you're
the promo code queer space queer space
they're gonna use that term queer space
makes up two percent of population earth
okay okay your identity because you're
an ass because of your behavior right
you're now just because you encourage
the milk shaking and battery and assault
of people who disagree with you that's
why I think you're an ass man it has
nothing to do with the fact that you're
an ass man it has nothing to do with the
fact that you are a gentleman and
scholar of Latino origin who happens to
be attracted to members of the same sex
which by the way is book brave and
beautiful okay the reason you're an ass
is because you want to remove every
single person who disagrees the queer
space that's two percent of population
earth
contrast that with 50 percent who are
conservative or right lean a grip yeah
by the way if you're talking about not
only conservative and right leaning but
people who at least don't believe that
conservatives are people who lean right
should be completely silenced let's say
it's at least six five right so YouTube
is saying okay we can either appeal to
everybody right we can appeal to the
vast majority of the American public the
global public who don't want to see
corporate censorship or two percent
because this guy thinks YouTube is a
queer space I thought it was
to be a suspect you guys didn't have any
content it was piano cat and turtles
humping work boots dance come on cuz
they need sure and this is really
important for people out there listen
this is if you think it's not going to
happen to you this isn't just for
conservatives now yeah okay yeah it's
everybody it's everybody who creates
original content because we have not
been attacked for being conservative
mind you at least that's not what I've
said it's offensive jokes yeah yeah so
if you do jokes that are offensive they
can completely remove your ability to
make a living so to give you a little
bit I really hope that people understand
here because if we move this is very
different from the other ad pocalypse
--is where it was offensive opinions on
political issues right this is now we're
getting rid of jokes now we're getting
rid of late-night programs and now we're
going after entertainers exclusively
because it might offend somebody not
because of libel not because of slander
not because of breaking the law not
because of actual targeted harassment
again I guess I have to say this
completely against daxing we've actually
found doctors and reported them who
didn't even Docs us because we're so
against it because it's happened to me
so guys make sure you reported Carlos
right when he died I don't want anyone
to hurt anybody of course and if it
happened to me I know you couldn't
withstand the kind of pressure that we
have here you wouldn't make it a day in
the Isis kill list
the ultra-premium frequent flyer mileage
that I have a crew the thing that
surprised me the most was that his
immediate response was I want everybody
to be et platfor I want him to be d
platform right right it wasn't good
enough that you were demonetized he said
that does no good whatsoever according
to whose opinion should somebody be de
platform well other independent
journalists and podcasts have already
been yes people who aren't even
necessarily conservative they're already
coming for you
for jokes or for even covering now yeah
controversial opinion what kind of humor
seriously what kind of humor out there
will defend zero people on the planet
this is one thing this is such a cop-out
to bite this is why I just hope people
know I don't agree with him thing you
know let's be clear about the man who
talked about his Lisbon happens to be a
queer producer as he labels himself I
think
it's too far how about committing
battery yeah that's why I met the point
I'm just gonna light up a big old [ __ ]
you cannon and walk away dancing okay
you want to do this fine let's let's go
down this trail I didn't want it to be
this way ladders better come /mo club
that's why we need you because we not
beholden to YouTube anymore but they're
like Streisand effect [ __ ]
have you seen do you know that have you
seen how many more here's the thing
people don't agree with this person just
like we've talked about on King house
most students aren't that far left it's
the professors who could actually yeah
yeah who capitulates yeah those there's
one person who complaints and gets us
banned from a campus one person who
complaints who wants to get all of you
all of you banned from YouTube and
here's the real the real challenge to us
we don't even know the rules so to give
you this is some of the exclusive
information half-asian allured bill
Richman is here we're waiting on an
email from them right finally someone
called one of my staff this morning and
said we think it's a real problem with
the socialism is for fake shirt which by
the way I appreciate that even YouTube
said it's socialism is for figs because
that leaves and it's always been titled
social mr. figs at the laterals better
shop not hilarious it's available there
and then this guy girls mom Isaac you
saying they keep saying that we're using
the word to connect well he keeps saying
that we say [ __ ] you're quoting him you
can say he sells the socialism for [ __ ]
shirt no that's not what I sell by the
way there is an irony here and I don't
want to get into theology and may you
never bear fruit again because you just
got really mad at the fig tree that's
kind of a component to it because
socialism doesn't yield great fruit but
there's also a component do you would
check over did to gay people yeah yeah
he forced them into labor camps find any
socialist or Marxist regime
do you know what they did a gate and I
don't say well that was a different time
Venezuela recently yeah every time so
you have to decide and that's one of the
ironies of the shirt sweetheart is
what's more offensive the ideology
that's led to the mass incarceration and
forced labor of people who are in
minority groups including gays
homosexuals take a very called or a joke
that's a little bit on the line if you
want to call yourself a Marxist you
aligned with the people who would put
you with the firing squads
that's what we fight against we don't
want to see anybody in front of the
firing squads that's why we don't wear
che guevara shirts let's be clear about
the truth here and
Vox it's 2% of our videos yeah and maybe
2% of those videos include making fun of
the guy yeah the rest of it is actually
surrounded surrounded by facts
information statistics which we make
couple to you hey Fox where's that yeah
right they wouldn't know about that it's
funny that those are missing from every
one of his videos every Fox's videos
don't want to make sure people
understand I missed him
we have been punching up anyways okay so
YouTube said they called right and this
morning and this is a half Asian lawyers
rubbish yes here he said a full day they
said we think it's about the social mr.
Figg shirt yeah and we think everyone at
YouTube is going to want you to remove
that shirt from the YouTube links right
right there was there was some concern
about some kind of removal regarding the
fig shirt and what it ultimately turned
into was a couple things one complete de
monetization from a global standpoint
right based on videos that are at times
multiple years old and some of which had
been manually reviewed and approved
that's important to note you went out
and met with them didn't actually meet
fine widgets keys yes I didn't yeah met
Susan Wojcicki so I know you guys didn't
set up a private meeting in her you know
glass office in Silicon Valley but you
did speak with her and I was there once
with you or there was a summit in New
York EDS are we within the guidelines
you're golden okay sources in you know
that and so that ultimately that that
was confirmed that they gave us one or
two titles they said that they would not
provide an exhaustive list of the videos
that are allegedly violating what first
is it was the shirt well they said it
was a sure and then they called back and
then they called a statement people did
at YouTube no names no information and
they read a statement and that was the
next step right correct so wouldn't give
full names wouldn't give emails wouldn't
give phone numbers they said they felt
uncomfortable telling me their
information to verify who they were so
of course I had to check the number this
was quite an intimidating figure I look
at me I don't know whether to run or put
change in your head
I mean put a violin in my hands man the
sadness for Carlos Mazda but but
ultimately the second call led to okay
fine
if you can't give us the list email us
the list you want to read it on the
phone it's so great all right fine
give me one example I just want to know
what is the violation and they they
hadn't sent that list and then they
tweeted out this is very important for
you leave out to the public and
specifically to Carlos Maz as far as I
understand this is saying to be
clarified so in order to reinstate
monetization on this channel he will
need to remove a link to his t-shirts
there's one link to the t-shirts yeah
yeah did you know it doesn't exist
anymore
remember it's gone all right that's
right the link was already gone did you
see Carlos is responsed oh no was not a
fuming I could not laugh hard enough
what would not it was just like what the
[ __ ] I'm quoting dying like I was just
absolutely dying I'm like there are no
emojis for what I'm feeling right now me
who's more angry you tell me who's more
hateful watch this show in its entirety
or that guy who wants to milkshake
everyone who disagrees with him is like
no no they have to be removed right we
just removed their ability to make a
living on a mug Club but you know no
they shouldn't be allowed a place at the
table at all into it the queer space win
okay so that's what was tweeted out we
are waiting on an I think we might have
just gotten we we did we did okay dude
this is an email from YouTube now
correct bringing news it was supposed to
be an exhaustive list of all the
egregious violations that we've
committed so that we can know if we can
reassess their term yes right right and
it's not they gave me two two examples
okay and they said that they that it's
not an exhaustive list but they gave two
examples of how many videos over them
over a thousand I mean they gave me
three examples on the call I mean they
didn't even give me the third example
the right gave me on the call and then
another one that just says the inclusion
of the figs t-shirt labelled it properly
again yeah and that's interesting you
know there is like you mentioned earlier
a lot of people who are saying that it's
a different word but even YouTube admits
that the shirt actually says socialism
right
so come on okay what are the examples
that they gave well the first one is
episode number 204 trans troupe ban oh
no February of 2017
what Wow wait yes wait the transfer ban
Blair White was on that show I was did
you watch it
did you so okay what the hell yeah all
right what was the other one so number
two was the the shirt the fake shirt now
number three was titled Muslim rape in
UK exposed by Tony bugle okay that's not
even a joke
that wasn't even a offensive joke Tony
bugle was talking about the Islamic rape
gangs in yeah okay if I'm not mistaken
she was a victim of sexual assault
herself she's written books on it
I remember that interview it was just an
interview by the way hate speech that's
apparently hate speech
how are the I mean what do you do with
this do with this this is the thing is
it the shirt is it not the shirt no one
can understand the rules in a hole so
you said it was offensive jokes you said
it was about going after the last guy
which we've never done again please no
and if I find anyone Daxing Carlos Massa
I will personally have them report it
and have them banned I will use our
entire team of researchers that is not
what worry about let's be as clear as
possible if you're watching Susan I hope
you heard me so can I can I just say
real quick but yeah um 2019 that is that
Muslim rape video no it's not it's not
2018 it's not 2017 it's not 2016 it's
actually from October 2015 is how long
YouTube has let that video be on its
program and monetize before it decided
which money to change and again not
making the change by letting us know
before right yes letting us know but
let's be honest is not they said it's
not a violation of their guidelines
right what they're saying is we did that
out yes they're saying this your
violation of their monetization
guideline right exactly rules not
exactly feckless [ __ ] you know we just
had someone who's ad active in sexually
assaulted talk about sexual assault in
the UK so again
this is very it's very hard to keep
track of what what this is it's not the
guidelines let's be really clear about
that yes this is another way they will
find a way to get you guys gone and I
mean everyone people who record they if
you if you've done anything in it during
was it live what do they call where they
live stream video games they call live
streaming but yeah I thought there was
some kind of a term for it there's got
to be a point is he's my neighbor I
don't know why the parents that spring
for some kind of composite yeah it would
have been better my sites 2020 I think I
wanted here's what here's what I would
say if anybody is out there right now
and they're like you know I don't like
steven crowder I don't like your brand
of comedy I don't like the things that
you say you you know it whatever you my
family have to do with this no no I
don't I don't you know whatever you may
say if you can't I'm being dead serious
if you cannot read AO C's green new deal
and that be okay there is there's no
standard at all that absolutely shows
you it's about the ideas that people
hold and not what they say if you've
ever live streaming videos what I was
about to say a live streaming of video
game event I keep getting it wrong and
that out of touch whipper snapper gaming
said something offensive they're going
to find it and by the way thank you I
think we have some tweets was it I I
think was a keemstar yeah philip
defranco kind of mentioned it yeah Chris
Reagan Chris Reagan the people about
yeah I'm pretty sure he's not a big fan
of mine a lot of people who don't even
like me have been talking about this
isn't about me and Vox this is really
about one of the biggest I guess multi
hyphenated corporations in new media
billion-dollar company wanting to make
sure that a guy who has a fraction of
the budget a fraction of the budget
right um
cannot effectively rebut their voice
it's not at this Carlos Mazda guy this
stuff was pushed out by Vox in
Washington and that's another thing
that's so funny with what first off if
you look at timelines from some of these
articles some of these articles if I'm
not mistaken had the guidelines before
YouTube released them or at the very
least was within like oh three minutes
ready to get exclusive Washington Post
reached out to me this is so special
they reached out to me later in the
evening and they had been working all
for this article that went out that of
course called me a racist homophobe
all that good stuff that means you know
you're doing comedy and make sure the
hodgetwins know you're racist they
probably don't want to come this show
ever again we did blackface and like
it's the Hajj they're black they are
black so one said we did yellow face but
it's not a thing that's not a face yeah
I got mad things made a lack face for
Shaun King I had to powder my face to
make it lighter he's no light we
actually used the film powder as the
blueprint we have the old VHS cover I
was just standing a lightning storm who
was remember it sounds like I've been
really saying no the Phantom it's not
something I committed to memory I was
talking about something before we talked
about patter oh I don't know Shaun King
that wasn't before Shaun King and racist
you raised there saying small of the
article Washington Post yes they reached
out to me Washington folks this is how
you know the media works first off
didn't reach out to me they sent an
email through the merch shop blotters
quite a shop that once again that's
where the fixtures available there's a
cop a Washington Post
there's a contact page yeah that's
correct research assignment number it
doesn't go straight to me so people hold
your foot there it goes right to our
press inquiries I think actually one of
the categories if I'm not mistaken is
press inquiries they didn't do that and
they said yeah but we're working on this
all day by the way you have an hour to
comment it was journalism guys are you a
dishonest journalist or are you just
lazy and sucky yeah why couldn't you be
bothered to put in the effort that we do
in trying to book a guest when we want a
book Andrew yang we call every single
number we have access to publicist agent
we get on Twitter we try and find out
how we can reach a new guest we hit all
fronts you guys didn't want to reach me
because you already had the narrative
set and this is important for everybody
else to understand the narrative is
already set from Vox from Vice from
Washington Post from the New York Times
they don't care this is a public
execution not of me because we're still
around and like we said we'll be okay
the more people who join up at Mudd Club
we have that promo code free speech
everyone gets a student discount right
now we're going to be okay it's not fun
but it is something that we can handle a
lot of other creators can't necessarily
handle this and that's also what's
really scary is this is kind of what
happened with old media where old media
just became so powerful that you had to
go through the gatekeepers remember
Joe Rogan talking about this in early
like Adam Carolla they were talking
about how with new me the great thing is
anyone can start a podcast yeah anyone
can get through right and there wasn't
any FCC well now the FCC is Vox its vice
yeah its YouTube its Facebook its
Twitter and they want to determine
what's okay and what is not okay to say
yeah you need to decide right now where
you even if you don't think the show is
funny again I don't know my family
necessarily has to do with this if you
don't let me to show if you don't like
the opinions that's not what this is
about
this is about understanding the rule
book and arbitrary guidelines that mean
they can remove anybody and it's already
happening they are coming for you you
think about happen it is going to happen
it is happening and it's so dangerous
for the smaller guys we've built
something up this is anything else do
your bullying how do we bully a
billion-dollar company yes that mugs and
this is also something else
all the stupid infighting and I don't
like ben shapiro I don't like Glenn Beck
on just okay do you have any idea the
gauge of the gun barrel you're staring
down right now yeah do you have any clue
it's time to put that stuff aside and
not only conservatives but everybody who
wants to be able to create content
online we do not have a billion dollars
we're funded by mugs and we have
licensing agreements with other
companies and thank God that we're not
no longer dependent on YouTube for
revenue yeah but the next guy
yeah isn't going to be able to do it
because Fox just like Amy Schumer just
likes uh what's her name of Sarah
Silverman yeah they got in with shock
humor right shock jock humor and then
they say we're gonna close the door
behind us yeah we're gonna make sure
that when you say gay do you know what
you say says Sarah Silverman and she
closes the door behind it's like you
made Holocaust jokes and joke about in
famine victims being pregnant teens I
thought it was funny back then but today
you would protest somebody for doing
that Fox but in Vice is a perfect
example
Tim Poole was talking about yes yeah
they are they used to be the punk rock
rebels and now they want to close the
door on everybody else who will be
coming up through the ranks the way they
did this is the big irony these people
who talk about this sort of this lack of
mobility of power this is why they
support socialist regimes that execute
or force gays into labor to ask because
if we need to break up to oligarchy the
systems of power well what do you think
is happening with Google YouTube
Facebook Twitter and all these other
companies that simply buy them up do
you've any idea how many entities Fox
owns give any idea how much was in
device by Disney by the way yeah you
know my said yeah punk-rock rebellion
they're talking about magic mushrooms in
in in Colorado wait a second is that a
secret Little Mermaid phallic symbol in
the back secretly subliminal imagery in
Disney the secret Disney subliminal
imagery in porn videos looks like a
chain in the air
I just want everyone to understand that
this is it's really not about us but I I
know there are a lot of smaller creators
out there who are concerned what is this
you know and for you it means that
unless everybody stands up and fights
back right now unless we all have a
meeting and get together and understand
what it is that we're facing and how we
can work together and we don't have to
agree on everything we don't even have
to agree on most things the new the next
generation come in they're not gonna
have a chance no they're not going to
have a chance it's never going to happen
for them it just like it'll never happen
for the next Sam Kinison the next Bill
Hicks it'll never happen for the next
stand-up comic who's breaking ground
it'll never happen now on YouTube it'll
never happen on social media unless
people start fighting back don't wait
until it's something that you agree with
or someone who you feel as a stamp of
approval on your worldview because
that's not what it's about
yeah well and you want to be able to
have all the guests that you want to you
want to be able to have people on here
that you disagree with I mean you've
done that multiple times bringing people
on and by the way to call you a racist
and a homophobe they're basically just
trying to just to put you in a category
so that everything that they say about
you after that people will just believe
oh he's a racist and a homophobe course
all this has to be true none of that's
true
do you have gay people on the show every
once in a while what doesn't mean that
wouldn't you have people who could have
gay people want to not be homophobic but
I don't think have you had I think those
gay people that were on the show your
friends would probably call you out for
being homophobic if you were homophobic
Yeah right you would think so I don't
know that they have yeah people would
say oh look you're sayin because I have
a gay friend it's a perfectly valid
argument if I hated Asians bill wouldn't
be allowed with my face to talk about it
they'd say hey a little less homophobic
or why don't you be a little less racist
by the way don't you train with more
people phobias right is it nothing you
like well what is it if I'm actually
homophobic how do I get over do I have
to touch the Vox guy is that like like
like you're I'm fairly certain he does
not want you to do that certain I don't
want you know what I'm certain
make it a queer I boxset I don't hell
but the point is that phobia I what I
want is for him to keep producing videos
I really really do because they are so
easy to tear apart yes like and the
ideal horrible the video the idea is of
course not him it's the ideas that we're
going after right right
he's putting these other things like
front and center and sometimes we see it
more like really the guy eating the
banana behind you okay that's why some
of those things come by the way it's not
it's not gonna stop it's not gonna stop
we don't want anyone to harass anybody
know as far as debunking ideas we'll
make sure we follow the guidelines once
we know what they are built that's why
he's here which but when Vox argued many
more rebuttals coming your way yeah well
you know a lot of people think eight
alternate platforms this is YouTube
we'll just go to somewhere else this is
going to follow yes it's not gonna stop
here if it happens here it's gonna
happen at bit shoot it's gonna happen at
Minds it's gonna happen at gap they're
gonna shut those places down right we're
we have to fight it here yes you have to
fight it you don't back up until you
find yourself in a corner and that's
what why we've done mug clip again we
have that promo code free speech is
because it allows us to stay on YouTube
on the free platform if we didn't have
my club we'd be gone right now yeah
general we'll be gone we everyone here
around probably get a couple months work
leave we try and you know take care some
people aren't left out in the cold but
we'd be done we'd be completely done
imagine that imagine your business model
anyone out there business anyone have to
anyone out there own a business or
anyone out there an employee of a small
business imagine you walk in the next
day and somebody has just absolutely
torched the joint Molotov cocktail you
have no idea who do you have no idea why
it's gone and someone say well stop
whining about it and you find out it was
just some guy who didn't like that you
told the joke at an open mic night
that's what that's what would happen
here yeah if not for Michael the paid
content that we create again so much
more content on the pay well maybe we'll
just put all the social is for Figgs
videos any video that has a shirt we'll
just put it behind the paywall yeah yeah
well put it there for mud club members
exclusively and that's probably a yeah
well I have no idea the issue here is is
that's what allows us to fight here on
YouTube the biggest delivery mechanism
that exists were the business
conservative channel on YouTube we're
very grateful for that and we have more
people on the show the hodgetwins for
example they now are the conservative
twins I was like I don't know why you
did that you're gonna get a lot of yeah
we figured we're in it now yeah we've
already been exposed and what are we
supposed to do every every April and May
in in preparation for Pride Month are we
supposed to kind of shut up about some
of these issues and make sure that we
don't like is this the is this the purge
you know pride cultural appropriation
months tomorrow is Canada Yeah right we
make fun of everybody equally too by the
way
more so ourselves in it you've probably
made more fun of yourself by dressing up
the way you have we're fun of anybody
could this is one thing you were talking
about to YouTube because they're saying
well at attacking anyone based on sexual
orientation is wrong and you brought up
the point right about Carlos masa well I
mean there was the time when he was
trying to insinuate that you were a
homosexual yes by in scene you know
wanting to know if if your wife knows
how often you were thinking about him or
looking at him and there's only really
two explanations either Mazda thinks
it's okay to use homosexuality as an
insult or he actually believes that
you're homosexual and now he's outing
you which is considered one of the most
immoral things you can do with regards
to someone's sexuality in a community
and so it's one of those things where
when you actually dig into beyond the
hysterics and the emotion and the
complaints and the crying you get to the
meat of what this is and the meat of it
is I don't have a substantive response
so I need you to be quiet right and I
need you to go somewhere else and I need
you to be done it's not again like you
said the two percent of the videos is
making some jokes making some sophomoric
humor using some terms that this guy
uses himself right because I'm clearly
gay
whereas with you Steven I'm just
committing it was liable written or
slander slander Anders oral libels
written well yes get away from oral we
don't know so yeah slandered libel it's
just slanderous libel is to say to imply
that I'm gay when we're not right you
know that I'm lying to my wife by the
way it's not really an insult that's
that like book it means I hit the gym
but they're so quick to weaponize it yes
right yeah absolutely it's the
inconsistency and of course advocating
actual physical violence so you want to
make and then I wanted to go to Bill and
ask for his expertise so this is this
one final thing and I forgot I brought
this up to you off the air the other day
when all this stuff was going down about
the video hold on hashtag Viva Vox ad
pocalypse keep it going right now
because make sure and figs we all fix
people and I'm seeing that right now
going
I think we should personally think
Carlos yes we should very much Carlos we
presented and maybe we can bring up some
tweets of that let us know if you use
the pre free speech promo code quartet
courtesy yeah Carlos Massa yes to get
your mug Club dis oh it's the video that
we were debunking last week I think for
Thursday show whatever it was they took
some of those outtakes and posted them
online and he was making like one of his
producers even said something you can go
and look at the videos like this might
actually sound offensive to you but you
actually sound gayer than normal they
were laughing and joking about like all
these things that I'm like I'm watching
this in my head is exploding because I'm
like we didn't go nearly that far what
is this like they can say it because
they're gay yes yes no no here's the
thing like he put gay walk gay look
right there he's making that and big
what a Marxist Pig and queer like all
these things and I get it like if we
were like saying you know caught like
very very mean like spirited like
calling him names and things like that
that's that's not what we were doing he
told that all [ __ ] Carlson white
supremacist yes bio commit battery
against white supremacist well who's
white supremacist Tucker Carlson it
pretty much anyone who disagrees with me
and my viewpoint he's notorious
pro-israel white sir if he had here's
the thing if he had any real talent and
what he was doing he would have taken
the fact that you debunked his video and
he would have piggybacked on it and
debunked what you had said because he
would have he would have seen he had a
large audience they would have seen that
and he would have good I would have
never even considered it as an option
but hopefully you are now Fox because I
would love to see that yes the dress we
do the merits of your doesn't have put
it in suggested feet because I know
autoplay after that hopefully will be
ours all we want is equal time yes I
really and here's the thing if they said
if YouTube said this they said listen
you can't say gay you can't we're gonna
retro actively ban all the words even
though we manually reviewed it and we
did it was fine and built when a half
asian lawyer bill was there and they
said no no we're good and we asked him
so many times whether this was a
violation of policies and they've been
very very clear but if they said listen
we've changed your mind we are a
publisher we are not a platform and you
cannot say anything that offends anybody
and we don't want conservatives here you
know what I'd walk off into the sunset I
don't want to but that's not what they
say yeah they court our biz
they say we would you know almost a
billion plays I don't know how many tens
of millions YouTube is made off of our
channel and they've said please come
broadcast with us
come advertise with us when we started
back in 2006 I believe my brother was
one of the first partners ever we did a
video the best impressions ever which
went viral for all the wrong reasons
troll before trolling was a thing yeah
and people can probably search her now
best impressions everyone it was there
was a rash on YouTube because it was in
2006 there's this rash on YouTube all
these horrible impression videos yeah
look I'm doing 55 impressions in one
minute and they weren't really
impressions yeah so what I did was I did
all these horrible impressions but I had
my brother as my Ed McMahon
it was just laughing at everything just
exactly always talks about pudding you
know this was before the rape back um
pretty rate wield on it and then I did a
Harrison Ford impression I'd actually
did a good impression and my brother was
like no one maybe needs a little bit of
work and then I go back and doing crappy
so but what happens is early on writing
this was back when trending was actually
based on real algorithms everyone
started warring in the comments section
yeah and it was because some people
didn't get the joke he's improved and
suck and then some people did get the
joke like yes the point is impression
suck this is sad terrible and then some
people did get the joke what we're mad
like I go through this is a joke but it
sucks and how there was my time and then
some people thought the impressions were
actually good oh just got a bunch of
comments and it got to the top back then
em I don't even think was called tren'la
like most discuss that motion stuffs
most top rated back when it was actually
a training right yeah and so my brother
was made a partner so back then their
argument keep in mind was they were
saying like listen at this point there
was uh there were a bunch of other
websites we know you have other options
you only have other options thank you
for flying Qantas they of other options
upload with us and we'll give you a
piece of the revenue yeah please stay
with us please help us build YouTube
yeah he said okay well I guess you're
the only place that's going to pay right
well guess what that did that squashed
out all the competition who couldn't
afford it at that time and then it only
got more sin if then I had way more
partners in the region city of Google
Google they had ad yet to make money I
don't know if they have made money yet
there a lot of people are canceling
their premium YouTube subscription I
don't necessarily know that that's a bad
idea right now yeah considering that
until they clarify what their guidelines
are but that's the issue is building a
business because they court
business and let's be honest here all of
you who stream video gaming all of you
younger people who have to doing makeup
tutorials
you picked YouTube because they made it
clear that you could make a living there
and now they want to pull that rug out
from under you they want you they want
to make tens of millions of dollars for
some of you hundreds of millions of
dollars off of you off of the backs of
your content and then remove you without
telling you why without a justification
if they say we don't want conservatives
if they say it's the social limits is
for Fig shirt and we refuse to fix it
and me tomorrow but that's not the
conversation right half-asian bill
Richman what is there a are there any
other updates what do we need what are
we doing well we are still waiting for
actual details in or instructions in or
non-ambiguous policies can be anything
but yeah I mean just in terms of the
responsiveness right I mean there's
certainly a question regarding free
speech and the ability to say socialism
is for figs or to use a shorter to make
the joke or make the social commentary
[Laughter]
shirts by the way you know not it is not
okay so you know so the point is is
figuring out what exactly is are the
rules gonna be right I mean in and
that's one of the things that was
directly asked today in the conversation
was you understand that you're now using
videos that were approved and that
you've made money off of for years and
years and years as the basis for a
suspension okay
tell us what the violation is right as
we still don't actually have even the
email we got today only says a couple of
examples of what the videos are but it
doesn't actually say what in the vivix
because it didn't do a review yeah
honestly it makes me here's the thing if
you were to say listen all right
here's you clearly doing blackface
here's your screaming the n-word at the
top of your lungs here are the really
egregious violations that we can clearly
they sit upon a further investigation
this is what they said I think on
Twitter they said they don't unit
further well on a second wouldn't you
want this to be as clear as possible
yeah yeah wouldn't you want them to know
whether of like listen you cannot be a
lot for example we have people who are
no longer allowed as guests in the show
it's like why because you committed an
act of violence against somebody else
because you tried to DOX them you are
not welcome
we make it as clear as possible because
we want that delineation yeah wouldn't
YouTube want that delineation if we were
the monsters they accuse us of being
they've given us no information out of
thousand videos to sue just let us know
the info you don't think they can do
that to you that's what people need to
understand here we appreciate so much
the support we've gotten and this is one
thing - I appreciate the conservatives
who don't necessarily agree with
everything I say but I said listen I'm
not gonna cop-out and say he shouldn't
mock well if the chicken why'd the
chicken cross the road no idea I'm
mocking you to get to the side every
joke every source of comedy comes from
some kind of pain misfortune of others
or mockery all of it from Groucho Marx
Jack Benny through Carol Burnett today
the Stephen Colbert [ __ ] holster -
Samantha be feckless Ken still trending
the point eight monetized you just need
to come out and say that you don't want
comedy and I appreciate that not only
there were so there been a lot of
conservatives the virtue signal like
well I'm the reasonable conservative
people like ben shapiro haven't done
that people like mark levin people like
glenn beck people like michael knows
people like andrew claiming but a lot of
independent content creators who are not
even conservative has said i don't i
don't care i don't care what it is that
he said i do appreciate your consistency
and everything we don't expect you to
jump into bed with us and and start d
monetizing your own videos all we're
saying is that everyone needs to get to
a table here and have a meeting and talk
because if they can go through over a
thousand videos they claim they've been
doing this for days they claim the video
that's two getting four dinners and just
say these two videos which aren't even
offensive one of them has a transgender
person in there blair white and the
other is about a victim of sexual a
victim of sexual assault who talks about
sexual assault in the UK those are the
only two references they gave us without
time codes what do you think they can do
to your channel they can get rid of you
at the drop of a hat
and they will the second they feel that
they have to because someone has wind
loudly enough and that's really the
concern yeah bill i guess what
what what are we're waiting on we just
we really were in a point where we're
gonna continue to make the kind of
reasonable Christ's who would make to
say you know through the various
channels we have both that YouTube
directly Google as a parent company
others who may be in this space would be
able to get to someone I think we can
all kind of see that YouTube's got a
little left hand right hand problem
going today with the various tweets and
I mean the number of tweets even from
Carlos Moses fans that are critiquing
YouTube's own actions is fairly
hilarious but funny here's one thing I
would say is a very big concern it for
those who still aren't convinced that
this could happen to them
right is it the rules have never been
the rules have always included if you
have one video that has issues we will
de monetize you and if you have a big
huge pattern of them then maybe we'll do
somebody monetize the video will do
monetize the one video right and so but
but today's conversation with YouTube
was even just one even just one example
we will use to ban you from monetization
on the platform and you have an example
I think the the the Colbert [ __ ] holster
example is actually a really good one
because you know who wrote an article
calling out Colbert as being homophobic
because of that comment oh please tell
me it was Vox really look at what they
did and they and so when you go look and
you see this kind of mass see
monetization related to Colbert do you
see a mass to monetization relate us may
it to be no you shows up in my feed next
to transgender makeup tutorials yeah I
have no idea why it's amazing magic I
know what is it they've said to they
reserve the right to change the change
at any point change their guidelines at
any point or change their mind on
whether it's a violation of guidelines
so that any point right that's what
they've said they reserve the right to
change their mind some other words that
could be guidelines we say it's fine and
then we change what we think is a
violation of guidelines to be clear this
has not been a violation of God I want
people to understand this so don't go
out there we haven't been banned from
YouTube just an ability to make revenue
off YouTube but thank God for MOOC thank
God that were funded by mugs we're not
exactly funded by Al Jazeera or Qatar
but you know this is this is the the
challenge is they're saying this is a
moving target we don't
we don't care whether they disagree the
people we just want to know what the
rules are and we know what the leftist
rules are right now what the PlayBook is
they want to get rid of anyone who
disagrees with them they've made it
clear Vox will not they will not rest
until everyone is gone and was it was
that half-asian bill Richmond are you
calling them over there Johnny boy
okay there's an update oh we have an
update now from YouTube okay what's
happening oh and I'm narrating right now
Johnny boy is talking with his hat and
is creepy creepy pedophile mustache
talking with half-asian Larry builder's
been a quarterback yet what are you
seeing going on there yes in the back of
Bill's head right now okay it looks like
they're talking about something as fuzzy
that's the Asian haircut doesn't matter
what they do they just got the shears
and a pop straight out we're saying what
town companies can't wait for these
companies to get what's coming to them
Vox suck you can see they can suck each
other just joined mug Club thank you
very much yes I can't really see from
here but oh man I'm sweaty
look at me look what's the do we have
the update there okay he's walking over
to his chair inna eye Sydney's putting
on his headset Shopify his decide to get
the shirt in our store what's so fun we
use what we use them it's a back-end
provider of the actual kind of store
okay type things but you know obviously
more complaints are being had more more
more more I don't like what you're
saying I don't like your art I don't
like your jokes well this is the thing
as they want to go after the advert and
that's where Carlos mods are really
screwed up in box screwed up they really
have awakened the sleeping giant because
people on YouTube ergo hang on a second
you're gonna screw this up for the rest
of us if you are saying we want to get
rid of advertisers and now they're
saying getting rid of advertisers isn't
enough so by the way we can find any
other cut there are their myriad
companies who said we'd like to host
your shopping so hey if you want to get
some revenue by the way this is
something else out there as well we have
wall through their fantastic sponsor we
have a couple of sponsors waiting in the
wings we've sort of been too busy
dealing with this kind of stuff to bring
them in but if you're a conservative
company out there and you want to reach
people we know that for every person who
finds this offensive there's probably
someone would pay twice as much for the
real of the advertising real estate
because we have a
retention rate and you know what our
audience is they support our they
support our sponsors we've never had a
sponsor of the show not be ecstatic and
we've always kind of had a handshake
agreement for a long time and where you
came in as a lawyer like wait what you
can content what money was you're not
spitting on the hands before you shake
them get a trusty Tim can do Blood
Brothers like in in how are you so fast
to my girl it's my number six movie
after constant after constantly okay so
let me go Shopify you know I don't care
yes I think they're not gonna be able to
this is one thing to when people like
we're gonna go to patreon they're gonna
they're gonna remove if we run Patriot
would be gone right now GoFundMe it
would be gone they can't pick away mug
club it's not something that anyone can
pull away that's the beauty of it we're
funded by mugs were funded by viewers
like you know PBS says that and they
sort of omit all the federal grant
dollars we don't get any I don't think
there's I'm gonna have some updates
tomorrow we're gonna have Dave Rubin on
the show and again if I reiterate one
point first off thank you so much for
the support we really are going to be
okay here and everyone here has been
great today we didn't plan on doing any
kind of a live stream nope but we just
had so much info coming in I don't know
how we compiled us into some kind of a
show tonight and we'll have some more
tomorrow
and hopefully within the next couple
days what actions we're going to be
taking because we need to figure out
where we are we need to figure out
exactly what our next steps are we don't
know you can't do that until you have
the rulebook in front of you what I do
want to leave you with though is if if
they can do it too now it includes late
night hosts and they've made sure
they've by the way identified us YouTube
has said it's socialism's for FIGS
they've said late night hosts right
they've smade really clear now Fox's
tried to make it seem as though we're
purely political commentary they've
omitted that we're comedy that's
something that's also important to know
our videos have always gone up in the
section of comedy our channels
categorizes comedy Fox tried to omit it
YouTube has acknowledged this is a
late-night show YouTube has acknowledged
it's socialism is for figs but to them
that's enough and so if an offensive
joke from a late-night comedians even
come close to [ __ ] holster a feckless
[ __ ] can warrant them being completely
booted from a partner sharing program of
which they've been a member for nearly a
decade
social zones for figs and a late-night
host telling an offensive joke what do
you think
can do to you what do you thinks they
are going to do to you and then when you
try to ask them why did you do that why
don't you pull the rug out from under me
and they don't have to answer and we've
set a precedent there bill Richmond
where no one's pressed them to answer
its you know you've heard the internet
referred to as the Wild West you
probably also heard it referred to as
the bathroom stall of society this would
really be the Wild West out house of
society at that point and you would be
you would be below the what is it
latrine where do they call it you drop
it the peen in the latrine is it called
a dream yes all right so we're gonna
have some more updates tomorrow really
appreciative hopefully we'll get some
answers from YouTube right now it's two
videos with no time codes no guidelines
ladders credit.com / Mudd Club enter the
promo code free speech you will get the
student discount even if you're not a
student because right now we are all
students we are all students of life and
I just encourage you to take this
journey with me and light up a big old
light up a big old mouth cannon and
let's just walk away flippin the bird if
this is how we go out if we're gonna go
out we're all gonna go out together and
I don't think that's what's gonna happen
I think long term we're gonna win this
and maza is still losing his mind so let
me tell you it's a good day above ground
we'll see you tomorrow live 8 p.m.
Eastern dave rubin
[Music]